bonjour sophie primas sénatrice des
yvelines secrétaire départemental des
républicains également vous êtes maire
d'aubergenville une commune de près de
12000 habitants que dans
l'arrondissement de mantes la jolie dans
cette émission on s'intéresse au
parcours des élus à leur engagement
aussi mais on débute toujours par une
petite partie liée à l'actualité
l'actualité assez notamment et depuis
quelques semaines voire quelques mois
déjà la loi travail puis saint malo à
travail l'adoption définitive du texte
est prévu le 20 juillet elle va repasser
une ultime fois devant les sénateurs est
ce que ceci fait texte est ce que ce
texte est un bon texte ce texte était un
bon texte à l'origine et puis à force de
négociations il s'est affadi et un texte
que nous aurions plus tout à fait
soutenir devient un texte il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'ampleur qui n'a de l'ampleur
que dans les effets qu'il a dans la rue
qui sont assez désastreux sur l'image de
la france et du progrès qui doit être
accomplie on a eu aussi un passage par
le 49 3 devant l'assemblée est ce que
c'était un bon choix ou pas c'est s est
toujours là l'ambiguïté avec le
gouvernement c'est comme le gouvernement
est parti sur un mensonge et fait l
inverse de ce pour quoi il a été élu
on peut dire que 49 roi est un déni d'un
déni de démocratie en ce sens maintenant
l'outil 49,3 n'est pas un déni de
démocratie c'est un outil qui permet
quand l'assemblée n'est pas très solides
en terme de majorité de faire passer des
textes auxquels le gouvernement croit et
pour lequel il s'est battu la difficulté
c'est que ils font inverse les ce qu'ils
ont promis
donc c'est ça qui est un peu ambigu
je reviens sur le sur le fond de ce
texte sur cette loi travailler qu'est ce
qu'il manque dans ce texte
aujourd'hui et si jamais aux missions la
droite aussi être amené à revenir aux
affaires aux prochaines élections qu'est
ce qu'il faudra changer
je pense qu'il faut vraiment s'attaquer
au code du travail on sait maintenant un
peu une tarte à la crème de le dire je
pense qu'il faut remettre la négociation
au plus près de la réalité territoriale
je pense qu'il faut mettre quelques
garde-fous mais il n'empêche qu'il faut
mettre là la négociation au plus près de
l'entreprise au plus près des vrais
salariés qui travaillent dans
l'entreprise il faut refaire une faune
de la représentation syndicale ce
qu'aujourd'hui on est très très
éloignées d'un une représentation
démocratique des salariés on est très
très éloignée ces systèmes là il faut
remettre un petit peu de flexibilité
tout en protégeant les salariés il
s'agit pas de laisser en rase campagne
les salariés on a besoin d' équilibre
mais on a besoin surtout d'ouvrir les
fenêtres et de simplifier les choses et
de flexi de rendre les choses beaucoup
plus flexible vous propose d'écouter un
micro-trottoir justement sur cette loi
travail d'encore est ce que le prochain
gouvernement va devoir revenir ou non
sur cette loi travail c'est la question
que nous sommes allés poser à 50 ans je
pense pas qu'ils vont le faire mais ils
devraient m'est égal parce qu'on la
connaît même pas
on est dans la rue pour ce truc là et on
sait même pas ce qu'il ya dedans des
jaloux à travail c'est tout le code du
travail qu'il faut revoir ces voix là il
ya tellement de choses à revoir que oui
à tout pavé travailla aussi bien laisser
les cdd
il ya la fonction publique aussi à
revoir à tous les statuts voilà tout
tout tout est à revoir tout le code du
travail dans sa globalité
je pense que oui parce que
pour moi la ni queue ni tête enfin elle
ressemble à rien quand il ya beaucoup de
choses qui sont pas
j'ai un plaisir tout à revoir en fait
après les pas si mauvaise que ça mais il
ya des choses il ya beaucoup de choses
quand même inchangé pour la protection
du salarié tout simplement oui mais pour
la
pour revenir dans sa version initiale
donc à une attente en tout cas là
beaucoup de bon sens dans tout ce qui
est dit et puis c'est très intéressant
parce qu'on voit en même temps que les
blocages qu'on a observés dans la rue ne
sont pas l'expression réelle de ce que
pensent les français et je trouve qu'il
ya beaucoup de bon sens ne m'attendais
pas à ça en réalité sur le micro
trottoir et je suis agréablement
surprise par la lucidité en fait
quelques réactions encore sur des sur un
sujet d'actualité c'est la sortie du
royaume-uni de l'europe
aussi est-ce que ça peut être une
aubaine pour la france et pour paris
aussi je sais pas s'il faut le regarder
comme ça moi ça me seulement sa
présidente de région valérie pécresse en
ambulance oui déjà l'entreprise dans la
région par les opportunistes sur cette
affaire et à la raison puisqu'elle a
beaucoup d'ambition pour la région ile
de france et qu'elle a raison d'en avoir
et qu'elle a raison de dire un petit peu
la star de cameron je crois qu'ils
avaient dit les entreprises françaises
de venir à londres
évidemment sans la réaction ne pouvait
être que celle là moi ça me rend un peu
triste pour l'europe parce que je pense
qu'on s'est engluée dans une europe
technocratique administratif qui manque
de vision et de souffle et j'aimerais
que cette jaillir cet incident de
parcours mais c'est plus qu'un incident
de parcours que c'était à deux faits
soit le moment de vraiment remettre
toute l'europe en question et de
réécrire la volonté de l'europe et
d'expliquer aussi aux français
d'où on est parti comme on a fait cette
europe
et puis de corriger tous les défauts
qu'elle a c'est comme pour la loi
travail a aussi beaucoup de pédagogie
d'explication à faire
oui oui il ya beaucoup sur les deux
géants absolue mais ça ça concerne
l'ensemble de la classe politique pour
le coup ça concerne l'ensemble de la
classe ultime c'est moi j'aime bien
emmener
d des gens de la société civile visiter
alors ça s'appelle maintenant airbus
safran launcher aux mureaux parce que
c'est l'expression même de ce que peut
donner les roms voilà lancé ariane dans
les airs à voir sur ce site des mureaux
qui n'a parfois pas bonne réputation les
nouveaux avoir autant d'intelligence
collective et d'intelligence européen
eee grâce à des fonctions des fonds
européens
c'est l'expression même de ce code
devrait être l'europe quelque chose qui
fait rêver quelque chose qui donne un
élan à l'ensemble des pays dans après
chacun a ses intérêts on voit bien dans
les dons les négociations sur l'espace
l'allemagne la france l'italie
l'angleterre tout ça ça se tire et c'est
pour avoir ou l'industrie sur son
territoire mais au bout du compte on
fait des merveilles ensemble et ce n'est
possible qu ensemble c'est ça l'idée de
l'europe est un art questions sur cette
actualité plus légères nous sommes au
mois de juillet les vacances qui ont
déjà commencé ou qui vont bientôt
arriver il ya eu un sondage de
ouest-france récemment à vous deviez
partir en vacances avec un homme ou une
femme politique qui choisiriez vous les
hommes ont répondu marion maréchal-le
pen est plutôt de nicolas sarkozy ou
jean luc mélenchon et vous alors c'est
très dangereux comme c'est très très
dangereux comme j'imagine à écouter ma
réponse comme françois fillon par
maréchal le pen ça non voilà nicolas
sarkozy je le vois suffisamment dans
l'année pour prendre des vacances je
pense que non pourquoi pas françois
fillon ouais pourquoi pas mais justement
devenir accord la seconde partie on fait
juste une pause
le café politique aujourd'hui avec
sophie primas sénatrice des yvelines
depuis 2011 vous êtes né en 1962
ingénieur agronome de formation premier
mandat politique c'était en 2001
adjointe au maire d'aubergenville
pourquoi cette volonté de s'impliquer en
politique et puis aussi pourquoi ces
deux communes des yvelines alors cette
commune d'eysines parce que j'y suis né
où quasiment 1 j habite depuis 50 ans
donc je suis très impliquée dans la vie
locale je les connais évidemment bien ma
commune je les aime beaucoup
pourquoi en 2001 ben parce que après
m'être engagé l'âge de 18 ans je crois
que la première fois je me suis présenté
aux élections municipales
c'était avec madame nelly rodi et ça
devait être je devais avoir 20 ans 19
ans 20 ans avec mon père d'ailleurs donc
c'était assez rigolo moi j'avais fait ma
vie personnelle ma vie professionnelle
étudiante et puis j'étais revenue
habiter cette ville mes enfants
commençaient à être grand et c'est à
cette époque là que j'ai décidé voilà de
de rendre à ma ville ce qu'elle m'avait
un peu données et donc de m'impliquer
dans la vie politique déjà bloc al plus
jeunes et en famille il y avait déjà
cette fibre politique et cette envie de
faire de la police cette fibre en
politique pour rien de vous cacher
j'habitais mes parents habitent et à
deux maisons de la permanence
parlementaire d'henri cuq qui était
notre député à l'époque et donc les
dimanches après midi est plutôt les
samedis après-midi d'ailleurs se passait
dans mon jardin sous le cerisier à
refaire le monde est à refaire la france
en parlant beaucoup de jacques chirac à
l'époque mais pourquoi cette affinité
justement alors avec l'ump les
républicains aujourd'hui on voir le rpr
sûrement plus loin mais le vpn voilà
c'est ça ma première carte est une carte
du rpr simplement une affinité sur les
valeurs qui sont qui sont véhiculées par
par la droite avec une période que j'ai
trouvé une période difficile où on avait
honte d'être de droite et
nicolas sarkozy n'a pas toutes les
qualités mais il y en a beaucoup et dans
et dans ces cas dits t il à redonner aux
français de droite des raisons d'être à
droite et de dire sans sans honte un peu
con on est de droite ont même le mérite
quand même le travail qu'on aime des
valeurs de fraternité ont fait la
solidarité de façon différente
et puis qu'on aime la liberté la liberté
d'entreprendre la liberté de pensée et
ça ce sont des valeurs qui mois
l'intérêt c'est dans une tradition
gaulliste ici au sénat je fais partie de
évidemment l'amicale bouliste auprèsde
auprès de auprès de gérard larcher
et d'ailleurs si je peux me permettre
une petite digression vient de passer un
petit moment magique ou même de
rothschild qui louent un immeuble à
londres a retrouvé dans la cave le
drapeau bleu blanc rouge avec la croix
de lorraine qui était dans le génie dans
le bureau du général de gaulle c'est le
drapeau kessel en bureau du général de
gaulle elle vient de le remettre à la
légion et c'était un moment
particulièrement une mouvement que de
voir ce témoignage physique du passé
parler de cette tradition gaulliste et
des valeurs d'être aujourd'hui dire
qu'on est de droite qu'on a des valeurs
de droite mais être de droite aussi
c'est ça couvre un spectre très large
même quand même comme à gauche aussi
mais on va se concentrer sur la droite
sont beaucoup de tendances au sein de la
droite jsk pas de trop de temps dans ces
quelques fois un cap un peu difficile à
trouver à ce que tout ça va peut-être
après ce se réguler après la primaire
vous savez quand on regarde alors je
vais
peut-être raisonner par contraste quand
on regarde la gauche on voit ce que ça a
donné en 2012 c'est à dire une gauche
très hétérogène avec des idées très très
différente aujourd'hui
quand on regarde par exemple le vol des
écologistes aujourd'hui il est plus
souvent avec l'extrême gauche qui avec
les partis socialistes étaient
extrêmement curieux qu'on a vraiment là
des choses très très différents mais
pour en revenir sur la demie sur la
droite ou en commun entre jean frédéric
poisson par exemple alain juppé nicolas
sarkozy françois fillon chacun a une
vision un peu différente des choses
chacun une vision différente des choses
sur des points particuliers sur des
points particuliers selon jean frédéric
poisson par exemple il est très orienté
sur le mariage pour tous tes valeurs
sociétales et c'est tout en étant
libéral vous voyez mariton c'est pareil
des très libérales etc
donc on est plutôt dans une tendance
libérale avec un curseur social plus ou
moins plus ou moins poussés voilà c'est
ce curseur social peut-être la façon
d'exercer les compétences sociales qui
nous qui nous différencie dans l'est
dans les nuances on va dire je reprends
votre parcours politique donc sénatrice
depuis 2011 on a le sentiment tout de
même que les choses s'accélèrent aussi
pour vous depuis l'année dernière même
depuis 2014 ou devenue mère
véritablement d'aubergenville vous
devenez aussi peu de temps après
secrétaire départemental des
républicains au numéro deux juste
derrière david douillet
il ya une petite accélération pour vous
aujourd'hui vous le ressentez comme ça
vous avez aussi une volonté de vous
impliquer encore plus de prendre des
responsabilités
en réalité il ya une accélération depuis
2010 puisque le décès d'henri cuq m'a
propulsé député à l'époque puis sénateur
dans les 18 mois qui ont suivi alors
j'étais encore dans la société civile et
que j'avais une activité professionnelle
monte depuis une vingtaine d'années je
m'attendais pas à aller aussi vite dans
la vie dans la vie politique
et puis ensuite vous est absorbée en
réalité c'est le monde politique qui
vous attendent par par an par son
intérêt pour les choses que vous avez
envie de faire les choses que vous avez
envie de noter voilà on est pris
j'allais dire dans l'actualité politique
et on est assez rapidement happé par
tout cela il se poste de sénateur
aujourd'hui ça représente quoi pour vous
sachant que on dit souvent que le sénat
- de pouvoir aussi c'est une chambre
d'enregistrement je sais que ça va senna
se sont dit c'est beaucoup avant de
connaître le sénat connaît très bien
en réalité les français connaissent peu
le cénacle s'y connaissent peu les
sénateurs et c'est normal puisque nous
sommes pas élus au scrutin direct et sur
les lieux au scrutin indirect par les
grands les grands électeurs et donc on
sert département tour ne sommes pas non
plus représentants du peuple français
nous sommes représentants des
collectivités territoriales et moi c'est
ce qui me plaît dans ce poste de
sénateur c'est à dire que nous
représentons les territoires dans leur
diversité en france
les nouveaux représentants tous les
territoires des communes de 150
habitants jusqu'au grand lyon nous
représentons l'ensemble des territoires
nous sommes indépendants de pouvoir
puisque le président de la république ne
peut pas nous dissoudre
contrairement à l'assemblée nationale
nous avons un tempo d'élections qui est
très différent et nous ne pouvons pas
actionner le 49-3 look ne sommes pas
simplement une chambre d'enregistrement
est d'ailleurs gérard larcher nous a
donné ces chiffres je crois hier il ya
plus
retailleau il ya 64 % des amendements
qui sont votées au sénat qui reste dans
la loi donc c'est pour dire que l'apport
du sénat est un apport beaucoup plus
serein beaucoup moins polémique beaucoup
plus dans le travail est un apport
fondamental à la loi moins passionnel en
lice des bases sont passionnés mais les
débats sont plus dans le détail sont
plus constructif regarde plus la
constitution regarde plus l'aspect
juridique voilà sont plus construit tout
simplement parce qu'on arrive en
deuxième lecture on arrive après la
première lecture de l'assemblée
nationale toujours très passionnel et on
vient un petit peu amendé corriger
compléter ce qui est fait par
l'assemblée nationale
puisqu'on parle des élections il ya un
scrutin aussi alors on parlait de la
présidentielle mais il ya les élections
législatives aussi vous allez regarder
forcément au détail dans votre
département des yvelines vous êtes je le
rappelle le numéro deux pour les pour
les républicains
les candidats ont déjà été très investis
désigné parce que tous presque tous sur
le quasiment toutes les circonscriptions
aujourd'hui les républicains avec ses
alliés comme lui d y possède dix des
douze circonscriptions temps et là vous
visez un grand chelem très clairement
oui alors me fait dire ça dans la presse
beaucoup que je dis qu'on visait un
grand chelem moi je vise le maximum de
postes c'est mon rôle
ce serait quand même curieux qu'une
secrétaire départemental disent non non
non surtout pas le grand chelem aussi
ont fait le grand chelem je suis ravi
maintenant est-ce que ça est ce que ça
sera comme ça je pense qu'il va y avoir
des circonscriptions où par l'arrivée du
front national par la force exprimée
lors des derniers scrutins sur le front
national nous allons devoir batailler
nous allons avoir des positions
difficiles il ya des circonscriptions
qui sont difficiles je pense à celles de
trappes élan pour la verrière qui sont
des circonscriptions difficile jean
michel fourgous le sait bien
donc nous rien n'est fait mais
évidemment je vise le grand chelem et je
ne sais pas quel secrétaire
départemental en france vous vers l
inverse avec le modem qui malgré tout
n'a pas apprécié tous les tous les choix
le modem qui a fait savoir aujourd'hui
qu'ils allaient aussi et qu'ils avaient
déjà prêt investi certains candidats ce
qui n'était pas d'accord avec les
désignations qui avait été fait par les
juges une supension que ce soit
exactement enfin je n'avais pas vu leur
communiqué de presse mais je ne suis pas
sûr qu'ils soient pas d'accord avec les
désignations
nous verrons de la désignation qui
avaient chacun on à son hôte tampon n'a
pas fait encore nos négociations que le
modem présente des candidats c'est
parfaitement son droit que lui dénie le
fasse également nous on l'a fait et puis
ensuite on on se parlera parce qu'il se
trouve qu'avec le président de l'udps et
le nouveau président dudit nouveau
président du modem on s'entend plutôt
bien et donc la négociation seront peut
être viril mais une mais néanmoins
amical au delà je reviens juste sur
cette notion de deux grands chelems au
delà bien évidemment et c'est légitime
cette volonté de gagner dans le plus
grand nombre de circonscriptions quelle
que soit la formation
il ya eu un autre grand chelem dans le
département des yvelines c'est au
conseil départemental aujourd'hui il
n'ya plus d'élus on va dire d'opposition
tout le monde est sous la même couleur
politique si pour le département des
yvelines
tous les députés étaient amenés à de la
même formation politique n'a pas une
inquiétude et un sujet préoccupant de se
dire où est la diversité politique est
ce que est ce que c'est pas inquiétant
même pour la place de la démocratie que
d'avoir des assemblées boucicaut l'or
s'est jamais trop sur la formation sait
jamais c'est jamais très bon d'être
monocolore parce qu'il faut de la place
à la discussion à l'émulation la
critique mais ça fait partie de la vie
politique songez pas d'illusions
là-dessus ça ça restera pas
éternellement complètement à droite ou
complètement à gauche dans certains
départements donc voilà c'est un épisode
qui est un épisode particulier de la
vidéo
line mais ce n'est qu'un épisode on va
parler de françois fillon
oui de la présidentielle avec piscine
spa fillon vous super vous l'avez
soutenu déjà en 2012 dans la résidence
de l'ump là vous le voyez porté les
couleurs de votre famille politique pour
le prochain scrutin présidentiel est
posée coûter encore un petit
micro-trottoir voilà quelles sont les
forces et faiblesses de françois fillon
d'abord ses faiblesses et que
malheureusement il était ministre d'un
ancien président qui n'a pas donné
satisfaction et sa force je pense que
c'est quelqu'un qui aspire confiance
malgré tout pour moi il sérieux mais
sable mais les politiques je sais pas
mais il semble sérieux je pense que il
est dépassé
pourquoi il a été un gouvernement je
pense qu'il ya des jeunes qui peuvent
avoir leur place donc place aux jeunes
mon françois fillon c'est un homme
d'expérience qui a déjà eu affaire au
gouvernement avec sarkozy a de mémoire
si on me demande si c'est le beau
président ou le futur président je ne
pense pas personnellement actuellement
sur la scène politique il n'a pas encore
montré sa force sa conviction et son
envie d'y aller
il a l'air un peu mou en fait ça c'est
l'art apple où il a la moindre caresse
que juppé donc je préférais juppé c'est
le mot de la forme 5 à 7 vous
l'important c'est tout le monde de tous
ces gens là et votez pas si sombres
servent aussi c'est important
justement dormait alors sur françois sur
cette question de de françois fillon l'a
entendu donc il était dépassée mais en
tout cas qu'il avait parmi ses succès en
inventant une confiance de choses c'est
là où je voulais rien il ya deux visions
en fait c'est soit il donne confiance
soit il a tout de même un handicap c'est
d'avoir été dans un précédent
gouvernement
alors quelles sont ses forces
aujourd'hui pour vous c'est fort c'est
justement d'avoir été dans un précédent
gouvernement
moi je pense que c'est une force et
c'est d'ailleurs une force qui assez
communément répandue chez tous les
candidats à la primaire si vous
et à part jacques myard jean frédéric
poisson voilà les autres ont participé à
un gouvernement
moi je crois qu'une des forces de
françois fillon sait de revendiquer
justement le fait d'avoir été premier
ministre de nicolas sarkozy
dans des périodes où il y avait des
réformes aussi affaires qui ont été
engagés parce qu'aujourd'hui m'oublie de
dire qu'il ya des réformes qui ont été
engagées qui ont été faites notamment la
réforme des retraites la réforme de
l'université
toutes ces réformes là sont allés se
sont allés au bout sans protestation et
149 3 il ya eu des grèves sur les inuits
a été soutenu d'ailleurs par françois
fillon je ferai remarquer et donc il a
cette expérience là de la réforme de
tenir bon de négocier les partenaires de
soutenir ses ministres et ça c'est
extrêmement important
donc tout ça il a cette expérience là
évidemment il a pas toujours été
d'accord avec nicolas sarkozy il a
communément il dit communément on parle
pas du bateau quand là il ya une tempête
on savait que cette crise financière a
été vraiment difficile et n'avait pas
envie de partir du bateau même s'ils
partageaient pas 100% des idées de
nicolas sarkozy il lui a été loyal et
moi je suis arrivé à l'assemblée
nationale à ce moment là et je peux vous
dire que la force et la détermination et
la loyauté de françois fillon à cette
époque là était sans questionnement à
gauche aujourd'hui un candidat qui se
dit en marche c'est emmanuel macron
voilà ministre ce qui pose des questions
mais en tout cas lui il se dit ni de
droite ni de gauche il faut fédérer il
faudra une nouvelle vision de la
politique vous en pensez quoi de cette
idée moi je pense que c'est pas une
bonne idée en réalité moi je je je
trouve que mâcon est un personnage
politique en lui même et que il a sa
place sur l'échiquier politique
peut-être s'est-il un peu trompé qu'on
aurait préféré l'avoir à droite c'est
qu'il a des idées qui sont plus libéral
que socialiste voilà
on peut dire les choses comme ça non moi
je pense que les français ont besoin de
repères et contrairement à ce qu'on dit
ne pas donner des repères ne pas
transmettre un message
c'est une erreur qui perd aujourd'hui la
société n'a besoin d'avoir des repères
de savoir quelle est la politique de
droite quelle est la politique de gauche
de savoir quelles sont les équipes quels
sont les fidélités quels sont les
loyautés quels sont les solidité pour
tenir un gouvernement
et cette espèce de ventre mou l'addon
poumons et essaye de se complaire
complaire aux états unis goût aux jeunes
et de droite c'est pas courageux et ça
ne répond pas à la transmission des
véritables valeurs qui fondent notre
république il faut réaffirmer sa couleur
politique il faut réunifier le jeu
politique même sérieusement et contraire
c'est facile de dire au moment où parti
socialiste n'a pas très bien on surtout
je suis pas debout aux charges suis pas
de droite non plus un mais je suis pas
de gauche non plus c'est pas courageux
sicile et à gauche aujourd'hui les
ministres du gouvernement un
gouvernement de françois hollande
alors je me demande ce qui fait et
qu'est ce qui fait qu'ils sortent s'il
n'est pas de gauche qu'ils s'en aillent
voilà dans les prochains jours la suite
de cet entretien on va prendre quelques
instants pour parler aussi bon travail
de sénatrice 9 mars 2016 au sénat vous
avez voté alors avec votre groupe vous
étiez contre l'introduction d'un seuil
de 20% de bio en restauration collective
publique d'ici et 2020 expliquez-nous
pourquoi parce que quand on parle de
restauration bio on peut dire que c'est
plutôt une bonne idée c'est alors c'est
une très très bonne idée mais simplement
j'en ai assez des normes
et toutes les collectivités
territoriales tous les maires que vous
rencontrez de grandes et de petites
ville vous dise on en a marre des normes
et voilà typiquement à partir d'une très
bonne idée qui est l'introduction de
l'alimentation bio dans les cantines
quelque chose qui s'apparente à une
langue qui est une norme les pouvoirs
publics et les collectivités
territoriales n'ont pas besoin d'une loi
pour faire du bio vous avez des
initiatives partout sur le territoire
qui font que les maires aujourd'hui
introduisit le bio sans avoir besoin de
normes première chose deuxième chose si
vous mettez une norme
demain les grands groupes de
restauration devant l'obligation d'avoir
20 % que vont chercher les sources de
bio et comme on n'est pas en capacité
aujourd'hui d'avoir et les agriculteurs
et surtout la filière bio qui permettent
de servir les grands groupes de
restauration collective et bien les
grands groupes de restauration
collective ils vont aller ailleurs en
europe chercher de l'eau est donc le
résultat est exactement inverse de
l'objectif corps était poursuivi par la
loi donc liberté liberté aux
collectivités territoriales et stop aux
normes à 4 norme aujourd'hui quels que
soient les reproches les faits à
l'europe aux siens mais 400000 norme sur
une collectivité territoriale
un maire devrait connaître dans sa tête
de mr 400000 normes qui s'appliquent à
sa commune c'est juste pas possible
à un moment il faut mettre en relation
ce qu'on fait est ce qu on dit tous les
tous les parlementaires d y être nommé
entraîneur me mettre aux normes
et puis pof on fait une loi le lendemain
pour une raison que je comprends en font
mais qui n'est jamais que l'expression
d'une nouvelle norme
voilà toujours dans le cadre du sénat
vous avez par le passé approuvé le
principe de solidarité écologique mais
vous considérer qu'au 6 est une source
d'inquiétude pour les acteurs
économiques là aussi il faut
laisser aussi concrètement les secteurs
économiques comme les collectivités un
petit peu travaillé dans le bon sens en
fait en fait c'est très important de
cette notion de solidarité écologique si
elle est bien bordé d'un point de vue
juridique voilà c'est ce que redoute
tout le monde les uns et les autres
c'est savoir où ça commence la
solidarité écologique et où ça s'arrête
est ce qu'on peut dans 20 ans dans
trente ans est rappelé en responsabilité
sur quelque chose qui a dérivé et qu'on
ne connaissait pas à l'origine voilà
c'est l'insécurité juridique qui pose
quelques soucis et quelques inquiétudes
ou plus que le principe même des queues
de solidarité écologique mais ce qu on a
fait surtout au sénat sur la loi
environnement c'est surtout le préjudice
écologique qui était une proposition de
loi de notre président groupe bruno
retailleau qui a eu beaucoup à faire
avec l'erika sur ses côtes
et c'est lui qui avait fait cette
proposition de loi et nous l'avons
introduit dans le projet de loi du
gouvernement
ça c'est une très belle avancée du sénat
ce texte là et pour conclure on arrive à
la fin de cette émission aujourd'hui les
autres combats en politique s'il me
devait y en avoir qu'un seul il combat
le plus important que vous souhaitez
porter combat en politique c'est lutter
contre la centralisation qui est en
train de s'opérer
c'est à dire que ce pouvoir et ce
gouvernement est en train de
recentraliser complètement la france en
donnant tous les pouvoirs à
l'administration et en redonnant tous
les pouvoirs à paris je suis très
inquiète
et alors je vais vous dire quelque chose
qui est totalement non populaire je suis
très inquiète du non cumul des mandats
parce que ça c'est quelque chose qui va
centraliser la décision de politique
éloigner la politique du territoire
je pense que c'est mortifère pour les
assemblées c'est même peut-être
mortifère pour la vème république
de plus avoir des élus qui peuvent
siéger à la fois par exemple dans une
commune être aussi voilà je parle pas
d'un immense témoin s'il faut lâcher son
indemnité d'élue locale jlh c'est pas le
problème le problème c'est d'avoir la
réalité de ce que nous faisons la
réalité des territoires
si nous avons des parlementaires qui
sont cinq jours sur sept ici au sénat et
à l'assemblée nationale ne seront plus
sur leur territoire et ça c'est grave
merci sophie primas d'avoir participé à
ce café politique enregistré cette fois
ci non loin du sc n'a l'émission
reviendra à la rentrée très belles
vacances